okay starting off we've got this work
object that's got all of my jobs in it
very cool and then we come down to the
bottom here and we find the location
Iser function location Iser is taking in
the work object from above and let's
take a look inside of it we start off by
initializing a new array which in this
case is called location array and it
starts off empty and then we've got a
foreign loop this foreign loop is going
to iterate over every job within work
object jobs so remember work object is
the object that we have up here it's
being passed in and we're going to
iterate through all of the jobs in it
for each of the new jobs we're going to
create a variable and don't worry it's
going to get overwritten every time we
run through this loop the variable is
called new location and we're going to
set it equal to the location of each job
so let's break this down a little bit
we've got the work object and then
within the work object we've got the
jobs array and now because of the for in
loop we've got the index of each job
within the job's array within the work
object and then for each job we want the
location so we're just going to use dot
notation to get the location once we
have each location we're gonna push them
using the dot push array method so we'll
start off with the name of the array
that we want to return later and we'll
do dot push with new location as the
parameter once this for loop is finished
we're going to return the location array
which we created earlier all right let's
go ahead and see if this works I will
come down here and let's console.log
location Iser and we'll pass in the work
object from above and if all goes well
we should see an array of the locations
where I worked well hit test run scroll
down and there we go the log says that
I've worked in Mountain View Seattle and
I've had two jobs in Nashville